le nord de la colombie britannique dans
les années 1980
des forêts sont littéralement rasé par
la machinerie lourde des compagnies
forestières et pour éviter que cela ne
se produise sur leur territoire les
oueds souhaité haine et leurs voisins
les guides san décide de poursuivre la
province d chef héréditaire dont le modo
au centre qu'on surnomme des le gamou
qui veulent faire reconnaître leurs
droits ancestraux sur un territoire de
milliers de kilomètres carrés après un
revers en première instance la cour
suprême du canada se prononcent et
donnent raison au wat souhaitaient une
décision aux allures de victoire pour
tous les peuples autochtones au pays
si des gens blancs vue d'utiliser les
territoires des indiens
il faut que les gens négociés ou
compensés comprennent fait de
compensation jusqu'ici la couronne avait
reconnu aux autochtones un droit d'
usage de la terre c'est à dire qu'il
pouvait chasser pêcher
trapé mais ça ne voulait pas dire que la
terre leur appartenait delga manque un
type beaucoup plus loin en disant que
les amérindiens non seulement pour avoir
des droits d'utilisation limité à la
terre mais en plus ils peuvent prétendre
détenir un titre
un droit pratiquement équivalent un
droit de propriété
cet expert apporte une nuance importante
la cour a reconnu un titre ancestrales
aux oueds souhaitait mais elle n'a pas
déterminé quelle portion du territoire
leur appartient elle ne leur a pas non
plus donné de droit de veto sur des
projets gaziers par exemple la
colombie-britannique et les oueds
souhaité end devait négocier ces
questions mais ils ne se sont jamais
entendus
moi je tenais pas de précédent dans
aucun tribunal qui a reconnu ce plan le
chef héréditaire depuis la côte crème de
la ligne finalement qu'est le site
existe c'est bien
négocier la ressent et depuis 1997 où
cette décision eu lieu
on le voit aujourd'hui sa toujours pas
été réglée ce juriste autochtone et ex
député provincial rappelle qu'en
colombie-britannique et au québec
d'ailleurs la majorité du territoire et
n'ont cédé ce vide juridique créé une
incertitude et pour lui il est clair
qu'il y à un perdant dans cette histoire
tout le temps on nation autochtone de
prouver son titre ancestrale donc tout
une question de preuves qui est hyper
lourd qui est hyper complexe qui est
hyper cher pour des communautés qui sont
souvent très très bas ou déjà davance
faudrait qu'il y ait une présomption
légale pour qu'on puisse renverser ça
pour dire ça serait au courant
fédéral ou provincial de prouver le
contraire mieux définir à qui appartient
le territoire un pas important vers une
vraie réconciliation ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada montréal